Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P here is a caller commenting on
fox news host Laura Ingraham last week linking
cannabis to mass shootings. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hey, David. Susan from Chicago,
Cummings commenting on Laura Ingraham and her
ridiculous marijuana conclusion. Yep. I can
assure you that people are still marijuana,
are not out committing crime. We were at home
eating frozen cookie dough in our pajamas. So
keep that in mind and have a nice day.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And of course, this the
stereotype of the cannabis user is relaxed, low
key, not out there committing violent crimes. And
generally speaking, that's accurate. There are
some studies we've talked about which can link
cannabis to people kind of predisposed to
aggressive behavior in some of them. There
have been some studies that say cannabis can sort
of and enliven that tendency, but no evidence
whatsoever of a causal relationship between
cannabis and violent crime. That's what the
facts and the best studies we have tell us. As of
right now, I don't even know that Laura Ingraham
really believes it, but it's certainly something
I mean, listen, don't latch on to anything.
For the first few days after the Texas shooting,
it was doors too many doors open, doors unlocked,
doors. Then it shifted to other things. Well, it's
mental illness, but you guys always vote against
funding for mental illness. Well, so it's
probably some other thing. Maybe now it's
cannabis. Cannabis psychosis is another
thing they're pointing to. Their only goal is
don't talk about guns. That's the one piece we
can't talk about anything else. They'll blow,
smoke up your, you know, wherever in your
nostrils, but the gun piece you can't talk about.
We'll see what happens over the next week
with this forthcoming vote in the House
on banning assault weapons. Can Democrats find
ten Republicans in the Senate to get to 60
and would they have the votes of all
50? Democrats is also a fair question
to pass an assault weapons ban. I think by Friday
we'll have a much better idea. We have a fantastic
bonus show for you today. Among other stories,
we will talk about the Supreme Court deciding
to allow states to use illegally gerrymandered
Republican district maps in the 2022 midterm
elections. What? Why? We will talk about that
and much more on today's bonus show. Sign up at
join Pacman dot com and remember that you
can use the coupon code at big voting 22.
Speaker 4: Surrounded by water big.
Speaker 1: Water not big water just
big voting big voting 22 to get a discount
off of a membership at join KAYAK Links.